إذا كانت ميلانيا ترامب تشاهد هذا ، فماذا
تريدها أن تعرف الشخص الصعب
أو تقول له ،
نعم ، ماذا يمكنك أن تقول إلا أنا آسف
، أنا آسف لأنني لا أريد أن أفعل ذلك معي
، أنا آسف لذلك ما حدث  بعد أن
كنت حميميًا
جيدًا بعد أن كنا في الأسمنت ،
حاول أن يدفع لي وأنا في الواقع لم أكن
أعرف كيف آخذ ذلك ، هل
حاول فعلاً أن يسلمك المال لم
يقل ، أعني أنني حصلت للتو  هذه النظرة
لا أعرف فقط لا أعرف حتى
كيف أصفها ، لا بد أن المظهر في وجهي
كان حزينًا للغاية لأنني
لم أحصل على مثل هذا المال من قبل من قبل
رقم واحد أو رقم اثنين
اعتقدت أنه يعتقد ذلك  أنا في هذا من
أجل المال أو لماذا أنا هنا الليلة أو هل
هذا شيء طبيعي لم أكن أعرفه ولكني
نظرت إليه وقلت هذا ليس
أنا أنا لست من هذا النوع من
الفتيات وقال أوه وهو  قلت إنك
مميز حقًا وكنت أشكرك ، لذلك
غادرت ، لقد ركبت السيارة بالفعل حتى
يصطحبني كيث إلى المنزل وبدأت في
البكاء وكنت حزينًا حقًا وكان الأمر
لقد جرحتني لكني عدت